Você sabia que aquele cafezinho logo
depois do almoço pode estar te roubando
energia em vez de dar? Pois é, parece
contraditório, mas deixa eu te explicar.
Olha só, o café contém substâncias
chamadas polifenóis, principalmente os
taninos, que se ligam ao ferro dos
alimentos que você acabou de comer. E o
problema é que essa ligação impede seu
intestino de absorver esse ferro
direito. E ferro, como você sabe, é
fundamental pra energia, pra força
muscular, pra oxigenação do corpo todo.
Veja bem, a maior parte da absorção do
ferro acontece nos primeiros minutos
depois que você come. Então, quando você
tomar café logo em seguida, é justamente
nesse momento crítico que os taninos vão
lá e atrapalham tudo. E não é só o café,
não. É chá preto, chá verde e até vinho
tem o mesmo efeito. Ah, e os laticínios
também, porque o cálcio compete com
ferro na absorção. A dica prática é
simples. Espera pelo menos uma hora
depois de comer para tomar o seu café.
Se você já tem tendência a ferro baixo,
aumenta esse intervalo ou diminui a
quantidade. Testa essa mudança por
algumas semanas e me conta se sentiu
diferença na sua disposição.